[Music]  we continue at 4 30 with the ongoing  investigation into a deadly fourth of  july parade shooting in highland park  illinois about an hour north of chicago  this is a live look nearby the scene  this afternoon we now have a look at the  man police believe is involved in this  horrific shooting from this morning  thank you for staying with us i'm brian  loftis and i'm christian casadas well  investigators are looking for this man  22 year old robert bobby cremo and have  identified him as a person of interest  police say six people are dead and  another 24 were seriously wounded when a  gunman opened a fire during a fourth of  july parade witnesses say they saw the  shooter fire from a rooftop just 10  minutes after the celebration started  the community has been asked to shelter  in place until the gunman is found